bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'on
vide de lecture la télé wolf tout va
bien parce qu'on va parler d'un cinéaste
qu'on d'abord et oui michel audiard
c'est ça et avec avec un essai
extraordinaire parce qu'il est il est
extrêmement original peut il aider de il
est signé de fabrice de fait rares
bonjour bonjour
fait rare vous enseigner le droit à
l'université de reims et vous est
également l'auteur de deux romans et
d'ouvragés bien qui mêle le droit et le
cinéma comme le droit selon star trek
est évidemment comme votre dernière
parution consacré à michel audiard
liberté égalité fraternité parce que
c'est bien michel audiard
on va parler aujourd'hui du fils patxi
c'est évidemment a évidemment même s'il
est peut-être plus connu que son père
roger rosello des jeunes aujourd'hui à
peut-être qu'on peut demander à fabrice
d'être que les jeunes connaissent plus
aujourd'hui de le fils audiard que
michel audiard
ben disons que les derniers films de
michel audiard c'est 1985
donc pour les jeunes générations cccc
encore plus loin que la préhistoire et
puis surtout surtout une chaîne audiard
et jacques audiard en dépit de leurs
liens ne n'exerçait pas tout à fait la
même activité à celle aux biens a dirigé
quelques films mais il est
essentiellement dié le liste est rude
heures départ cas de jacques audiard est
plutôt est demandé dans des registres
très différents en effet oui oui c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire
essai de donc ce scénariste ce
formidable dialoguiste dont on va parler
michel audiard mais on va d'abord se
rafraîchir un petit peu la mémoire je
pense que quand on mettra les cons sur
orbite a pas fini de tourner quand ça
ose tout le relais c'est vrai quelle
différence y entrant un conte est un
voleur non un voleur de temps en temps
ça se repose la connerie à ce point là
moi je dis que ça devient gênant
[Musique]
vous êtes blessé dans la nature comment
je vais rentrer mois les champignons
avec une alternative open
en connaître
c'est du brutal
j'ai raison et curieux j'ai collé une
polonaise comprenait au petit déjeuner
faut quand même admettre et plus tôt une
passion d'hommes mais moi les dindes les
soigne je vais les faire une ordonnance
et une série je vais lui montrer qui
c'est raoul pour quatre coins de paris
qu' on va le retrouver est appuyé par
petits bouts façon puzzle
moi quand on m'en fait trop chaud
correctionne plus jeu dynamique je
disperse je ventile alors voilà quelques
petits extraits à pour se rafraîchir la
bulle moi ça fait toujours du bien ça
fait toujours plaisir d'entendre ces
dialogues absolument incroyable alors il
ya eu beaucoup de livres sur sur michel
audiard sur sur ces mots d'auteur que
détesté d'ailleurs la nouvelle vague sur
son enfance cette enfance d'enfants
abandonnés sur son goût pour le vélo sur
son goût pour les baux sur le fait qu'il
a commencé comme journaliste avant
d'être repéré par le par le cinéma
mais une analyse des principes
juridiques qui nourrissent explique
l'oeuvre du réalisateur de faut pas
prendre les enfants du bon dieu pour des
canards sauvages
il y en a jamais eu alors deux questions
rapide d'abord d'où comment vous est née
cette idée de faire cette analyse
juridique et puis deuxième interrogation
sur le sous titre du livre
la devise de la république liberté
égalité fraternité
pourquoi vous avez un verte et pourquoi
dans ce dans ce livre c'est liberté
fraternité égalité oui alors comment
s'agissant de ce goût pour michel
audiard et bien je dois dire que comme
comme obélix et la potion magique je
suis tombé dedans étant petit donc cela
ne m'a pas été très difficile de revenir
et de me replonger dans l'oeuvre de
michel audiard
ce qui s'est passé c'est que et et on
s'en rend compte en voyant la vidéo que
vous venez projeté c'est que ces mots
d'auteur ses phrases chocs qui sont
celles que l'on retient millionnaire
beaucoup d'autres en fait elles ont leur
propre énergie
elles existent indépendamment du film et
on peut les ressortir au cours de
conversations et elles produisent le
même effet que d'un effet sidérant en
effet comique un effet truculent qui
sont propres à certains dialogues
d'audiard
et donc ce que j'ai fait c'est que je me
suis rendu compte que si l'on écoutait
les dialogues d'audiard mais
indépendamment du film de son histoire
de des images et du scénario on
s'apercevait que ces dialogues en fait
avait avaient leur propre signification
et l'idée m'est venue ensuite de en
visionnant toutes les tous les films de
michel audiard de me dire que au fond il
existait une sorte de fil d'ariane de
fil rouge dans tous ces dialogues qui
témoignait indépendamment des oeuvres
t-il dans lesquels s'expriment et qui
témoignaient d'une pensée personnelle
extrêmement profonde et riche dans
lequel il nous propose en quelque sorte
sa vision est bien de l'organisation
sociale des institutions
des rapports entre les hommes et les
femmes et et nous livre sa lecture du
monde dans lequel il a vécu c'est à dire
finalement entre son premier film qui
date de 1949 et son dernier 1985 en gros
il a traversé la moitié du 20e siècle la
deuxième moitié et pour la devise alors
pourquoi la version la devise le canton
quand on quand on lit ces dialogues on
s'aperçoit qu'il y à un certain nombre
de valeurs fondamentales qui sont
extrêmement importantes pour lui qui
sont la liberté qui sont l'amitié la
fraternité et puis ils envisagent les
rapports dans la société sous cette sous
une certaine égalité et d'un seul coup
ça m'a frappé et ayant ayant fait un peu
de droit jerry dias et c'est tout à fait
étrange cela ressemble à la devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
sauf que revus et corrigés par audiard
c'est d'abord la liberté qui est
essentiel puis la fraternité et enfin
ces deux va leur permettre d'avoir un
regard sur sa vision de l'égalité dans
les rapports sociaux
oui c'est un lit vraiment très riche
alors on va pas pouvoir rendre compte
comme ça en quelques minutes mais ils
sont reprend brièvement les principes et
bien auquel vous vous confronter l'offre
d'audiard alors 9 de diar pour rappel
c'est quand même 110 films une dizaine
de romans vous les connaissez sur le
bout des doigts alors on voit revenir
sur ces principes il d'abord la liberté
on s'envoie peu près d'ailleurs on a
beaucoup dit qu'audiard est un anar de
droite attachée à la liberté
individuelle et parfois même jusqu'à
l'excès ou pour parler comme les
juristes est ce que vous venez de dire
que vous avez fait un peu de droit
eh bien peut-être donc jusqu'à l'excès
peut-être même jusqu'à l'abus oui
d'accord les commandes et les poumons a
tenté de classer politiquement michel
audiard il s'est beaucoup amusé à
prêcher le vrai
faut tout ça n'avait pas pas beaucoup
d'importance pour lui jean gabin disait
comme vous le rappeliez qu'il était un
anarchiste de droite
moi j'ai considéré qu'il était plutôt à
l'arc aux légalistes c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui a la foi rejette par son
goût très très développé de la liberté
notamment de la liberté d'aller et venir
où la liberté de travailler de créer des
nez de de commandes de s'associer de et
bien cette cette liberté là comment
n'était pas possible sans quand même un
certain nombre de règles pour organiser
le fonctionnement de la société et your
la fraternité aussi vous montrer très
bien mais derrière cette centralité il
ya quand même peut-être l'amour allant
notamment la morale de la parole donnée
ont trahis pas ses frères ah oui ça
évidemment la commande chez audiard à la
fois la fraternité qui peut être par
exemple une fraternité d'armes telles
que les exposer dans un taxi pour
tobrouk par exemple où l'amitié les les
très anciennes amitiés comme dans les
vieux de la vieille bordas pourris ou
encore cette amitié coup de foudre qui
unit jean paul belmondo et jean gabin
dans un singe en hiver
cette amitié là elle est à la fois elle
se mérite puisqu'elle est choisi c'est
l'expression de la liberté chez audiard
mais en même temps elle impose des
devoirs et parmi les devoirs sûr il ya
la fidélité il y à la loyauté trahir ses
sons trahir l'amitié ccc pour ainsi dire
un crime et donc les sanctions sont
terrés chez la liberté fraternité on
voit l'égalité c'est peut-être plus
problématique mais plus inattendu mais
vous montrer au fond il ya une analyse
très très
très forte dit il rejoint souvent celle
des criminologues d'ailleurs c'est de
dire au fond les les but que poursuit le
monde légale et que poursuit le monde
illégal c'est à peu près les mêmes et
puis il ya autre chose aussi je me pose
des questions rapidement c'est vrai
qu'on a beaucoup dit que qu'audiard et
et misogyne et vous montrer au fond que
les hommes sont aussi bien traités que
les femmes sont aussi bien traité que
des hommes pour une bonne raison c'est
que finalement elles ne valent pas mieux
que lui c'est à dire que que l'on soit
la société a tendance à faire des
césures entre le monde de la légalité et
le monde dans des cas comme on dit en
argot houleux et le monde le monde du
crime la pègre où on distingue entre la
condition des hommes et la condition des
femmes et effectivement il ya des
différences et notamment des différences
de valeurs des différences juridiques
mais au final dans le discours d'audiard
eh bien il dit que finalement ce sont
les mêmes gens et on trouve des des
commandos de dangereux voyons aussi bien
dans les cabinets ministériels que dans
les bas-fonds il la réalité judiciaire
d'ailleurs lui donnent raison
et puis ensuite le comment ceux qui
malgré leurs différences d'après audiard
à nîmes fondamentalement les êtres
humains qu'il s'agisse des sommes qu'ils
s'agissent des femmes c'est la cupidité
c'est à dire ce désir de s'enrichir le
plus vite possible et à moindre frais et
donc les hommes qui dans la société
d'audiard qui n'est que le reflet du
monde dans lequel il lui cette société
quand même plutôt suis sous influence si
nos sous domination masculine donc c'est
eux qui ont apple devant de la scène
pour pour accomplir ses dessins et puis
les femmes sont peut-être un peu plus en
retrait puisque elles ont moins de
droits mais elle utilise tout ce que la
nature ou les systèmes le système
juridique leur donne pour arriver
exactement au même résultat
et même bien mieux puisque chez audiard
les femmes sont infiniment plus
intelligente plus
plus coriace que le sont les hommes un
film comme la métamorphose des cloportes
nous montre un lino ventura qui de bout
en bout sera manipulé par plusieurs
femmes et épique il finira finalement
séjour derrière les barreaux et
totalement dépouillé et tout ça
évidemment avec avec beaucoup d'humour
mais qui nous montre que les la
victimisation ambiante descharnes n'est
pas elle ne fait pas partie de l'univers
d'audience et donc de ce point de vue là
il ya une certaine égalité va
malheureusement on va renvoyer aux
livres on aurait bien voulu parler par
exemple de votre théorie du conte du
coup on a vu des petits extraits qu'il
faut pas et qu'il faut pas ramassé
audiard ou bonbons os x est aussi
l'inventeur d'un langage mais on
trouvera tout ça dans ce livre donc ça
s'appelle les lois de michel audiard
d'ivresse liberté fraternité égalité et
csu publié chez marc et martin dans la
collection droit et cinéma merci
infiniment fabrice defferrard merci de
m'avoir reçu
[Musique]